40 days in the Bible means a period of
testing and
preparation but the 40 days in the
wilderness is to connect him with the
Israelites who spent 40 years in the
wilderness you want me to make that
connection yeah okay let's make that
connection why did he go 40 days in the
wilderness okay well first of all why
did Israel spend 40 years in the
wilderness now I'll show you that go to
Ezekiel chapter 4 and read Verses 4 to
six because here's what I want you to
see that a day represents a year a day
can be a year okay Ezekiel 4:
4-6
okay chapter 4 vers 4-6 Ezekiel chapter
4:
4-6 you're gonna see here that a day
represents a year pay attention guys a
day equals a year
watch your questions as a final because
fried right now okay then lie down on
your left side and place the iniquity of
the House of Israel on it you will bear
their iniquity for the number of days
you lie on your side for I have assigned
you the years of their iniquity
according to the number of days you lie
down 390 days so you will bear the
iniquity of the House of Israel when you
have completed these days lie down again
but on your right side and bear the
iniquity of the house of Judah I have
assigned you 40 days is a day for each
year there go so four what how many days
uh a day for each year 40 days so a day
equals a year right yep so if you spend
40 days that's 40 years yep now let's
see why Israel is punished by God to
remain in the desert for 40 years go to
numbers 13 31 to 34 31 to
33 numbers 1 31-
33 13 3133
yeah all right 13 3133 okay it says but
the men who had gone up with him
responded we can't attack the people
because they are stronger than we are
start at 31 right numbers 13 31 to 33
right uh 3133 yep yeah just want to make
sure uh but the men who had gone up with
him responded we can't attack the people
because they are stronger than we are so
they gave a negative report to the
Israelites about the land they had
scouted the land we passed through to
explore is one that devours its
inhabitants and all the people we saw in
it are men of great size we even saw the
Nephilim there the descendants of anak
come from the Nephilim to ourselves we
seem like Grasshoppers and we must have
seemed the same to them okay so when the
Scouts came back from Israel uh Canaan
they told the people the 10 because
there are 12 Spies yeah okay 10 of the
spies said said man the the inhabitants
of the land they're huge right they make
their inhabitants look like grasshoppers
the sons of anak anak their Nephilim the
word is Nephilim yeah and therefore it's
not safe to go but then Joshua and Caleb
two of them Joshua and Caleb said no
don't be afraid it's a land flowing with
milk and honey don't be scared God will
deliver him into our hands but the
people got afraid right y okay are you
catching it yeah so because the people
got afraid and the 10 spies got them
scared God says here's your punishment
go to numbers 14 33- 34 watch their
punishment all right numbers 13 3334 it
says let make sure this is 14 14 vers
3334 it says your children will be
shepherds in the wilderness for 40 years
and be bear the penalty for your acts of
unfaithfulness until all your corpses
lie scattered in the wilderness you will
bear the consequences of your iniquities
40 years based on the number of the 40
days that scouted the land a year for
each day oh wow okay did everyone catch
it God says because you doubted me and
you're afraid of the Giants more than my
power that I would destroy them it's
going to
be one year for each day it took them to
scout the land because you all of you
are gonna die your children will enter
not you pay attention you grown-ups
every one of you is going to die you're
not going to enter with exception of
Joshua and Caleb you're children will
enter Because by that time they'll be
grown but you that came out you all die
and did you know that all the people
that came out none of that original
generation went in not even Moses Aaron
Mariam only Joshua and Caleb all that
group died their children are young they
grew up and they
entered yep okay now now what did he say
why are you gonna spend 40 years each
year for each day it took them to scout
the land how long did it take him Scout
the land 40 days Days wow so 40 days is
equal to what 40 years okay now remember
Israel's God's son Exodus you don't need
to Exodus 4:22 Israel is my firstborn
son right yep so God's firstborn son is
sent into the Wilderness 40 years to be
trained and tested by God go to
Deuteronomy 815 and we're going to wrap
it up after this Deuteronomy 8 vers 1
and5 gonna see the connection with Jesus
Lord now Deuteronomy 8 verses one and5
all right it says carefully follow every
command I am giving you today so that
you may live and increase and may enter
and take possession of the land the Lord
swore to your ancestors remember that
the Lord your God LED you on the entire
Journey these 40 years in the wilderness
so that he might humble you and test you
to know that was to know that to know
what was in your heart whether or not
you would keep his commands he humbled
You by letting you go hungry then he
gave you Mana to eat which you and your
ancestors had not known so that you
might might learn that man does not live
on bread alone but on every word that
comes from the mouth of the Lord did you
catch verse three yeah why did God drive
them into the Wilderness for 40 years to
teach you and train you and discipline
you to depend on God because man shall
not live on bread alone but on every
word that proceeds from the mouth of
Yahweh right right yes and then if you
read continue on to five it says because
God is treating you as a son now watch
How It's going to tie in with Jesus all
right so five says keep in mind that the
Lord your God has been disciplining you
just as a man disciplined his son you
caught it right but did you read four
and five because you had three and you
skipped four oh hold on uh so three four
four says your cloth oh sorry your
clothing did not wear out and your feet
did not swell these 40 years keep in
mind that the Lord your God has been
disciplining and then he said that that
man does not leave on uh bread alone but
on every word of God and that's what uh
okay so why did God drive them into the
Wilderness 40 years to treat them as a
son to discipline and train them as a
son to depend on God not on bread right
yep and 40 years would be equivalent of
40 days yep now go to Matthew 4 verses
one to three okay amen guys pay
attention Israel's God's firstborn son
they went into the desert 40 year 40
years a year equivalent to a day to be
trained by God as a father disciplines a
son to depend on their father not on
bread alone now watch what Jesus does
Jesus is God's son look coming how many
days he spends in the wilderness and for
why all right it says then Jesus was led
up by the spirit Into the Wilderness to
be tempted by the devil after he had
fasted 40 days and 40 nights he was
hungry now remember a day is equal to
how much a year so Jesus's 40 days would
be equivalent to what one year so his 40
days would be equivalent to how many
years 40 years all right now keep
reading all right then The Temper the
tempter approached him and said if you
are the Son of God tell these stones to
become bread here's the connection he
answered it is written man must not live
on bread alone but not but on every word
that comes from the mouth of God he just
quoted Deuteronomy 83 yep but
Deuteronomy 83 is about God driving
Israel his firstborn son Into the
Wilderness for 40 years to teach them to
depend on God not on bread alone wow so
why did Jesus quote it about himself
because Jesus is God's true son and true
Israel so he's reliving the events of
Israel where the nation failed he
succeeds wow they failed in the desert
but this true Son of God true Israel
succeeded and
overcame wow that's your connection